okay so this is on I think we might as
well get started how are you today have
you enjoyed the coffee and the breakfast
and the thingies out there
how about the Keynote
it was very mind-opening at least for me
I think we're kinda ready cool uh thank
you for being here in such a large
number uh today we're going to talk
about
um well how to deep dive or to
embrace.net in grpc okay so um in.net so
I assume all of you are like dot net
developers or you have to deal with.net
code in your work life Okay cool so who
am I first my name is Irina dominte my
married name you'll find me as irina's
Corto on uh on social media I'm from
Romania I'm an independent consultant in
software architect it's always a love
with in love with.net Microsoft MVP I
organized the user group I teach.net and
I blog or you soon I'm not blogging as
much as I would I have at the last
numbering I had about 100 drafts
articles wannabe articles but they just
sit there
so uh if we're gonna talk about
microservices or fancy shiny new and
useful architectures where
we might as well talk about where we
first started with the monolith right so
um I must ask you who here loves
monolith or used to love monoliths
I'm Gilda's charge yeah and why is that
well because for the developer working
with a monolith was very easy life
when you had the monolith you had pretty
pretty much every thing in your code
base in one place and if you needed
something you could have gone and
instantiated that something use that and
everything was there
and one uh big plus over the monoliths
is that nowadays is not valid anymore
but back in the days 10 years ago when
you had such a big chunk of a solution
and you built you wanted to build the
thing you might have as well built the
solution and go outside grab a coffee
stay with your colleagues and so on it
was easy because the build time took
that long
so um one thing with the monolith was
that it's very hard to scale such thing
without losing a lot of money you had to
scale to monolith the entire thing like
put it in and create two instances of it
and usually the systems have parts that
are not that used anymore or uh are less
used than others and that's the deal
with microservices it allows you to
scale small parts of your app or your
system
so um
it's expensive to work with monoliths
nowadays and now we have to adapt to
Modern architectures
so when I first started working like 13
years ago
I started working with web forms does
anyone here remembers ASB web forms yay
it was cool isn't it to have components
and render that respond to uh different
events handlers and so on
nice and after that another programmatic
approach appeared SP MVC and it was such
breakthrough like asbnbc was the thing
everyone wanted to work with asbnbc it
had a clear separation of things
and then things started to move on and
the architecture started to be more uh
split like you had a front-end app and
then you had a back end and the back end
didn't render uh front-end code anymore
like web forms used to do where espnvc
used to do so now you have two parts of
any app to manage you have the client
app written in whatever.js we won't
mention that part and the backend API
that serves data to the client but we
all know that well the future is
distributed right and to save money uh
we kind of need to scale only the parts
of our system that are really in need of
scaling
and now uh the previous architecture
started to become like that
we have front-ends that use different
backend apis and basically they're
mixing everything together in one app
and then you have
some other architectures front-end
related but not we won't talk about them
right now so every backend has one
database or two databases and then maybe
one of the backends talks Downstream
with another backhand like a third-party
apis you need to integrate like server
to server with some other API or maybe
your business need has something like
this
like you need for example to have a
polyglot environment you might have
parts that are very suitable uh written
to be written in core or maybe node.js
and you need to consume those or maybe
you have a.net core or a third-party API
that you do not care in what language is
written and you need to mix it all
together and make it work and understand
each other
and now you might say okay so why do we
need grpc because we already have Json
and we already have the common language
between everything
so we all say that we Implement rest
apis
and I'm gonna ask you how many of you
are really implementing rest apis
yeah
my hand is down uh because basically
what we're most of us doing is HTTP apis
we're implementing apis that respond to
date and data to be served over the
network to whatever system right
so um that rest for everything or
restful apis is not good anymore it has
its own applicability if you want to
expose something to the public to the
outside world to be consumed but how
about Downstream apis
so ABI to API inside your system and
this is pretty much uh the thing that
we're going to talk today
so now
the client server architecture the most
easiest architecture that we know uh
it's based on request response where a
client being it maybe a server client in
general it doesn't need to be a
front-end app a client can also be an
API
so when it talks to a server and gets
data from a server it does something
under the hood called content
negotiation
and that under the hood
operation takes care of the format of
the request or you as the developer you
need to take care of these things like
what's the format of the request is Json
enough or what are the fields that are
saying ascending towards that client
what is the payload the the client has
enough data how is that data formatted
and so on so
if a request fails how do you handle
retries
do you implement your own thing to
handle retries how do you handle error
errors if something fails
how do you deal with authentication so
between two System Authentication is to
be there
so another thing that is not that easy
to deal with in in rest apis is what
happens if the model that you send to
the consumer where the response changes
you also need to kind of force your
consumer to change after your after you
right or you need to version your API in
such way that you won't break your
consumers now there's a different story
if you own the team where you have
access to the team that implements the
consumer
uh then you can go ahead and say hey
team you need to add this field or to
remove this field or to change the data
format of the field but usually uh some
apis that are exposed to the outside
world
don't know who are their consumers they
simply expose their apis and someone or
some system will consume the API think
about product companies I don't like
GitHub right GitHub is there we use it
every time but
pretty much there are a lot of
integration with GitHub right so GitHub
cannot go ahead and tell their clients
hey you need to change your expectancy
from me I am adding this field or I'm
removing this field this is deprecated
this is the process that takes time and
you can simply cannot call your consumer
hey change yourself I'm gonna change the
model I'm responding with so this is
difficult but if you also talk let's
think about one thing if you have two
different things the teams inside your
company that are working on separate
apis there's still a communication
between those teams like I'm changing
the model you need to change what you're
expecting from me and so on so you have
pretty much no Common Ground than to
expect and prevent errors like with
forward compatibility or backwards
compatibility
so pretty much this is
what is wrong with rest besides other
thing that we're we're gonna not talk
about uh right now so rest exposing
things over API in Json format usually
or XML and so on
takes communication it needs
communication needs to plan for the
future and you need to
expect that your consumer will change
over time and not when you want it
so getting back to RPC so RPC has a
concept
um has been around since I don't know I
think the 70s I wasn't around that time
but
um
RPC as a general concept will make
systems behave and look like they're
part of the same boundary
so RPC as a concept
I'm gonna ask you to look at some code
so we have an order and a call to a
create order of a specific request
c-sharp code here it doesn't matter what
um what it does behind the scene but we
interrogate was the payment process
status and regarding and looking at the
status of the payment we we try to check
that if it's successful we're gonna
arrange shipping for whatever that uh
order is uh the code looks pretty decent
I mean you can tell what's happening
just by looking at it it's rather
self-explanatory and if you look at this
you might say that our these are
Services between the same app right in
the same context in the monolith maybe
these are there
so you don't care about orchestrating
the microservices if these were
microservice architecture part and so on
but if what if I would tell you that the
process uh payment for a line of code
it's actually a network call so it's a
call over the wire to another API that
knows how to process a payment
or to respond with a payment status
so this does a travel over the network
it takes data from one side to another
it's not in process
so RPC has a
hole will make the code look local even
if the API that you're calling Under the
form of a method call it's under a
different uh system
a different server all together so it
has a cola method look and feel it's not
it's not create HTTP request of this
kind it's I'm going to call this method
I'm going to get the answer I'm going to
process the answer so because it has
this column method look and feel it's
very prone to errors
at least when you were using HTTP
clients or you have HTTP client
libraries you're you're aware that
they're in that moment a network call
will be made like make a HTTP client
call get something from another API
bring it back and process that and use
that
so with RPC the code will look like
you're just calling a method it's not
you being aware that an HTTP code will
be made so basically
um RPC as a concept will make a
distributed system look local and behave
like a monolith pretty much
so behaving like monolith means that
communication is made transparent it's
like you're looking through it and
you're not aware that is there
okay but what's the fast with grpc and
what's the deal with it in.net so a
short of History
um it started in 2001 as a Google
project internal one called stabi and
fast forwarding a few years they over
open source that
uh and in 2019 we got it in.net uh any
other language out there got grpcb4.net
and they have a grpc version that is
more stable and we they are able to use
it but with your pcn.net they there were
struggles and there still are but it's
more stable than um it was before
so grpc the one that we're going to use
in.net is contract based so you're
basically defining the thing that you're
exposing to the outside world and other
system
under the form of an interface with grpc
you will have no more code references so
no more nugget packages that contain
HTTP clients that know how to call
different apis traveling around so no
more code references that way a thing
with nugget packages is that
Distributing HTTP clients under this
form is a way of
also integrating business logic in there
and I've seen it so many times people
say hey I'm going to create a library
for this that knows how to call the API
X
and then this small Library not only
knows how to call Api X but as any other
business logic that shouldn't be in
there so uh we end up with spaghetti
gold all over the place
another thing with grpc is that it uses
HTTP 2 under the hood out of the box
it has a different serialization
mechanism so it's not Json serialization
it's protobuf which is binary and it
makes a smaller payload that's one perks
of using grpc it's available in many
languages we'll uh
which means that will allow you to
basically have polyglot environments if
you have a C plus plus a node.js or
whatever you can talk through grpc and
also it does code generation out of the
box for you like
you're implementing the stuff and you
also have code without you running tools
or whatever to obtain the code
so if you look back at how client
request response architecture will look
like
we introduced something in between so
now we won't have a simple request
response but an HTTP request we will
have something in between named
protophile that we're going to inspect
so this protophile is simply a
text-based file that has a specific
syntax
that describes what you're trying to
expose with your services
so let's have a look
first you need to say what is the syntax
version that you want to specify what is
the namespace that you want to generate
and what is the package that you want to
uh to allow there so what you'll do next
is to say hey I have a thing that I want
to expose and be able to consume
Downstream that is called fibo it's a
service called fibo from Fibonacci and
then I expose an operation and that
operation is of type RPC named compute
Fibonacci it has an input named request
request number and returns a Fibonacci
result
so the thing with grpc when you're
describing the service is that you
cannot have like no parameters you need
to have an input so an input being a
thing that you need to pass around even
if it contains nothing
it's still an input that needs to be
there
so one thing again returns one thing out
so
looking at the the types you have this
keyword name the message where you
describe the input and output basic from
basically for this so requested number
it's an n32 with a name number equals
one yeah that equals one it's not an
assignment is the order of the field in
the specific uh requested number
um type and when it gets built it's
basically a c-sharp property that you
would use in a normal sharp class but in
grpc language it's called the message so
class or message here same happens with
Fibonacci result you give it a name like
a property name and if you would have
more properties you would go uh below
write in property name and then equal to
to see that is the second in the order
in there so
I might ask you this sounds familiar
have you ever worked with
WCF
or soap services like that yeah
there you see how funny it is in in it
and software development there are some
Concepts that tend to die and then after
a few years resurface under a different
form so this is one of those forms
so one of the cool things about grpc is
that it supports something that is
called types or modes uh it's unary like
request response the easiest way as we
we all know from client server request
response server streaming client
streaming and the community combination
of the previous two and if we were to
look at the animation how you describe
this is you have a client you have a
server as you have in any other uh
architecture so two entities like
talking with each other the client
initiates a request a HTTP request and
then the server receives the request and
sends the response back so one thing in
one thing out in the unary type how
would you describe such thing as Service
as simply as you've seen before before
input type returns output type and
that's it uh the next one called server
streaming
um it's similar the client still needs
to initiate a request so it's not like
server go hey you do something the
client still needs to open a
communication line with the server
uh but now if the server streams it
means that it sends several pieces of
data under the same TCP connection so
one thing in several things out and you
depict this just by adding the stream
keyword near the part that you want to
be it as a stream
so in this case I have one thing in
requested number and returns a stream of
Fibonacci result so many things out
the next one client streaming it's
pretty much similar but the other way
around the client still needs to open a
communication line it sends several
pieces of data
the server receives the data and sends
back one thing like one response think
about this how would work for example uh
upload things you chunk the thing and
upload the bytes and so on or maybe
collect data from different
sensors like if you have 100 sensors
every one of those will open one
communication lines the one connection
and send several pieces of data in
instead of having 100 sensors opening a
new connection every time they want to
send data so this is HTTP 2 under the
hood and this is why it's possible
so 100 and many things in versus 100 or
multiplied by whatever many things you
want to send to the server so how you uh
you write this that you're going to
expose
just by adding the string keyword near
the part that you want to be as a stream
so in our case
several stream in and one thing out
and the last one uh is the same but it
has several things in several things out
so combine the two of them and you'll
have bi-directional streaming so a quick
note this happens over single TCP
connection so online of communication
and many things traveling back and forth
how do you write this so by adding the
stream keyword just remove things in and
a string of a stream of things out
cool let's see some code
and
I'm gonna show you how you create such a
I hope it's visible enough I'm going to
try to zoom it so basically in Visual
Studio you have the project template
that it comes
um oh whoa whoa
and you click next you give it whatever
name you want
and it will end up creating a solution
file for you we I just want to show you
the how the project structure looks
because it will look the same in my
demos
so
um
I think you all work with the web API or
you had uh or MVC where you had the
controller folder very well organized
well in grpc you have no controllers
but you have produce folder and you have
a Services folder and the rest of the
things they're familiar app settings
where you can read and configure things
program Cs and so on by looking at
programs yes
I hope this is visible
further down
okay how do you basically activate a
grpc thingy so you just add the
middleware add your PC
and then you need to say hey I'm gonna
mop a grpc service called this way so
this is part of the template it gets
generated but I'm going to show you how
it gets generated
so looking at the protofile
we'll see here that uh it's a service
that expose an RPC method called say
hello
and it has two types the input type and
the output type hello request hello
reply
and basically what you need to do is to
give an implementation for this it's
like an interface you have the
protophile that specifies what you want
from your server but it's still your
jump to your job to implement the actual
um
the actual content so you have a greater
service
okay so greater service it's a class
that will inherit this
a greater greater base this is the code
that is generated for you so it's part
of the template and the code generation
that is there
this is the base class that is generated
in order for you to
override what's inside
for example I'm gonna F12 in here
to show you some funky code
you see that this is abstract partial
class greater base that has pretty much
what I need so it looks at the gr the
protophile and will generate a stab
what's here right here
say hello so you're basically overriding
this method that is generated for you so
in the service you just go ahead
override the method give it that hey I
get one thing in I'm gonna have to
return this out like the message type
okay one thing with grpc
service implementations is that
if you specified hey I have one input
you when you override the method you
also have this second parameter or third
or fourth parameter called server call
context which is similar to what we
already know from HTTP clients like the
context of the current request well this
is the context of the grpc request so if
you have a client streaming you can
access things related to this piece of
information by using the server called
context and on top of it you have the
HTTP context that you all know
cool
um
what we have in terms of packages
is grpcsb and net core and a specific
version this is what you need to add
and pretty much you have a server
implementation and another thing that
you can do with any other for example I
will I have and I'm gonna show you
console apps you can edit the project
file
and you're gonna say Hey you will find a
file a Proto file under this path and
this path is not necessarily to be under
the same project it can be on a network
it can be on disks somewhere but you
need to make sure that the protofile
will be accessible by all the apps that
need to consume it
uh and also another thing that you need
to add in here is that uh hey uh this
specific project is of type grpc server
server
so you add this parameter in here with
the value to depict that is the server
that will serve a grpc request
so uh enough with this
uh let's have a quick look at my Demos
in here
so what I have I have a server that has
the four methods implemented
and then I'm going to have four console
apps unary bi-directional client
streaming and server streaming that are
nothing more than console apps doing
requests to the server so in this
specific case you will have to have a
server running
and the client that makes requests with
a server to get responses back so let's
see how the server server looks
protophile
I'm specifying the four methods
so it's called still called the gritter
it's I am exposing to say hello once
again one thing out and for any other uh
method I have a stream of request in
returns one thing and so on the name of
the method it's a rather
um I try to be a very uh intuitive and
what I have in here is the what I send
so a request with a property called
content value and the response with the
property name message okay so these are
the this is the protophile and then for
uh one consumer I'm gonna show you that
I have no code references
so I have here
and I'm going to show you why I have
that many packages
so packages I'm not seeing a reference
to the server so no the only thing that
I need to add in common with this
project is in the Cs project itself
I have this
protobuf include
to make it reach the protofile that
lives on the server project file project
so you might as well have it in any
other place on top of your um
your specific dotnet project and in this
case I'm specifying that is a client
instead of a server as I used before
okay so I'm going to close all this
and I'm gonna get back to the service
server story to show you how things will
go so say hello
um
it's an overridden
overrides of the base class it has one
thing in it has the several contacts
that you can access and it basically
sends back what you send in with some
extra
um
strings like I'm going to say hello back
with what I send value from the host
server
and I'm going to show you one thing
before I dig more into the code so I
have a console to the left hand side
that I'm going to run and here the
server instance will just listen for
incoming requests
so it will listen on this
Port 5000 so server running up and
running and then on the right hand side
I will also have a console with that
console application running the console
app so what I will do is to run this
and if everything works fine
I should see things moving so what I'm
sending from the client part I'm sending
NDC
and I get a Hello back with NDC value
from this particular server so I added
this just because I wanted to show you
some more things in the end so let's
have a look what the server side to see
what happened and I hope is big enough
so on the server side some things
happened a request came in and then the
request came in for localhost 5000
greeter greeter say hello without type
of application grpc so it's not
application Json or whatever we used to
do it's application grpc it has a 200 a
status code but that status code is at
the TCP connection level so HTTP
Communication channel it took that
amount of type
and it's a HTTP tool and another thing
it's a post request
so everything that goes to a grpc method
call its post
so no matter if you're getting data you
do a post
because we used to do way back where we
didn't use like uh HTTP methods so
getting things
post you're sending things Post Yeah so
every other request is it's a post
request cool so classical client client
server request response and if we were
to look at the code in the client
there are a few things that we need to
talk about for example so
um
grpc talks in channels
and clients
so in order to make a requests over grpc
server you need to open a channel you
need to specify with the which is the
address and then you can specify some
Channel options like credential if there
there's the case but in our case we're
going to do insecure calls because we
like it that way
and then we're going to use the client
and you'll see that you have greater
greater client and this is not code that
I written this is auto-generated for you
when it discovers the protophile so a
greater client you pass the channel so
the communication channel to that port
uh and that's it you create a request
message as I told you cannot issue
requests that have no values so you need
to use those messages that you described
in the service
and then you simply just do clients call
the method that you want and that's it
so in our case we have say hello client
stream server stream bi-directional and
so on already implemented on the server
so this will be visible in your clients
okay so you've seen this working
and some other things that you can pass
around is that you can do some options
for every grpc request so it opens the
communication Channel and inside it a
lot of things related to grpc Will
Travel and sometimes you need to access
those things
so
um you can also pass some other things
like
you need to pass metadata in it I'm
going to uncover but I'm gonna get back
to it like later
uh I'm not writing gold like because I
don't want you to see me like how I type
badly so
um you can pass headers but these
headers are poor grpc requests not at
the uh the HTTP request level you can
pass it a deadline uh for example if you
say hey if you do not get back from the
server in that a lot of time consider
yourself uh dead that's the timeline
that you have to get back a response if
you don't then well throw an exception
and also you can pass cancellation
tokens if you need
so let's see the server is still running
listening and from the unary console I'm
gonna run it again and if things go well
we're gonna see an exception which is
what which was intended I'm gonna make
this uh more readable so we got an on
handle exception uh an RPC exception
with status code deadline exit is so on
and so forth so this is what we wanted
to obtain so well
one millisecond it's super super small
amount of time
so we got this cool
um the second one so we're still
listening for incoming requests we're
gonna see how client streaming works so
I'm gonna.net run it
and you'll see on the server that things
are getting in
a lot of things are moving
you see I got a request to It Whatever
content value and so on so a lot of
things
and the client got one single response
so the the this value is the last value
received from the server which is
corresponding to this
the actual implementation for it is
on the service here
so it's client streaming it's basically
a loop
sorry
uh that goes
at the way it's request right and it
simply writes the request that it gets
from the payload okay so you're looking
at the request stream
when you override this you'll get an
request stream that's why the stream
keyword in there and the server called
context and you will be able to access
the request stream and extract key from
things from uh from there for for
example when you still have things move
next and access the the current uh
thingy that it's traveling through there
so in the client stream
client this time in the console app the
scenario is pretty much the same for
every other example that I did as a for
Loop going to this value at just sending
request requests towards the server so
it loops and send creates a new request
and then waits for the last response
there and you see here
um
canceled I need to you can catch
exceptions but you need to filter those
exceptions uh over status code
and that status code it's different than
what we used to use with HTTP there is
still an okay but that's not HTTP okay
result it's related to the specific grpc
inside for example out of range invalid
argument deadline extended in our case
uh data loss canceled and so on and so
forth so status code for the specific
grpc one
so client streaming we watch this let's
see the server streaming
so you see the information in there
still running
I'm gonna run this
server is
streaming back things
from the um from the server side
so several things out one thing in okay
and you're gonna see some things in
there
like found some trailer values in grpc
header
that I'm gonna look show you
so basically in server streaming
you have a way of sending several
options uh in the the request you see so
I'm waiting for each response in the
response stream I'm reading all the
response stream
and I can search for a key uh for a
value for key sorry get value Mike fake
header and you can write that back
cool and bi-directional and then I have
some more example to show you server
still running
and guess what
it's going to send 10 things in
and
it's going to get 10 things out but
don't get fooled this ordering is not
guaranteed like
on how HTTP is working so I was lucky
this time so I'm sending the eyes and
I'm receiving the eyes back again
okay in bi-directional It's a
combination of the two so you're calling
the method that you're exposing to the
protophile and you wait for everything
to come in and then you'll wait for the
things to come out
cool
um let's show you some more things we
talked about trailer values
and I said I'm gonna show you
how you can extract things from the
context so you have the server called
context where you can get the HTTP
context of the specific grpc request and
you can get things like which is the
what's the user for the current you can
get the claims or maybe you can get the
client certificate that is best for that
connection and you'll be able to do this
in inside every other grpc method that
you're exposing another thing is that
you can
mimic headers for grpc requests in terms
of they allow you to um to send headers
back to the client not that the HTTP
level but at the grpc one so how you do
that uh you simply just add to that
context response trailer and you add a
key with a value
and that will be uh traveling towards
your client
and just
just add it to the response just as you
would you uh would do with the
traditional header in HTTP but this is
down beneath
okay
um let's see what else I was supposed to
show you right now okay
moving back to the slides
because I have some more things
talking about grpc interns internals so
until now we talked about okay how
things are working what you can do and
so on but internally
grpc status codes are different than
HTTP status codes as I told you you have
when you catch an exception for example
you need to filter out by what happened
so this is inside
the communication channel so these are
different another thing that you can
use with your grpc request is RPC
exception guess what with grpc you have
one exception type it's like exception
the gold class so
um in here you have RPC exception if you
want to deal with RPC
well basically what's inside it's up to
you to discover
so RPC exception
uh looking at the code
server
side
oh sorry sorry sorry
you can catch exceptions
and you can treat them like differently
when the status goes off that specific
exception
it's on a specific range and you can
also use this for a retries and we're
going to talk about that soon enough
okay so capture PC exception catch again
on RPC exception if what specific status
code happened and you can treat them
them this way
okay
um
request headers
so when you issue a call you can add a
request header uh when you issue a
response header again you can add those
trailers to the context and it will be
visible on the client and the same
happens with response uh trailer and so
on but one thing is that you still have
access to what you had before HTTP
context the top level you can add there
things that are visible and um
in the HTTP code so if you're talking
thinking about implementing this you can
also tweak some things and you should
tweak some things for example you can
enable detailed errors just by putting
this on true you can configure the
maximum size of the request if you have
of scenarios where I know you upload
things and you want to limit each chunk
of data that goes to the server then you
can add this configure it as an option I
don't know two megabytes or more or less
depending on the scenario you can set
what is the maximum of the message size
again depending on some computation you
might need to um to implement
to think about sorry so um another thing
that is a good practice even in apis
were in things like well ASB and VC is
regarding the compression level of the
response so you can add different
compression types in here and you can
say that hey I want compression level to
be optimal and it will work things for
you or maybe I want to use a compression
algorithm that is gzip or whatever and
you can add that in here or maybe you
want to implement your own compression
provider or add your broader compression
or why not your own you can add this in
here another thing that is the
worth mentioning uh it's called
Interceptor and it's a
similar thing to what a middleware is
right but this time the Interceptor
intercepts uh different types of grpc
requests so if you're talking unary
and that it's a blocking call you can
create an Interceptor and you override
that
also interceptors are of Two Types on
the server side you can add that like I
added in here it's generic and can
create your own or you can intercept
things when you send the request over
the server so you basically you'll be
able to create something that is like a
I know a pipeline just to add more
things in
um in the grpc request like you would do
like with a normal middleware
uh let's see such an interceptor
so for example in the client side
uh it's I created an error Handler
Interceptor but I not uh it doesn't not
get through it so um Interceptor you
inherited this class and you override
what you need for example I need to
intercept when things are like a calling
grpc unary like blocking
sorry async uh you have some weird
things like there the context and the
continuation again it will wait for the
next
um Interceptor if there is one uh just
like it happens with the middleware you
pass the control back and then control
the gas back to you
um and well you can
add things in here another thing that
you can add
is Interceptor at the server level for
example you can Implement a logging
Interceptor I don't know to not
necessarily too long but even to trace
things related to grpc requests you can
pass parameters if there's the case you
can inject things and for example I need
to um
pass the unit server Handler uh server
call contacts and to log things like hey
I'm starting to receive a call of this
type you see you're awaiting the
continuation for the content request and
so on and if you want to activate this
you simply need to go into the grpc part
and just add it in the server server
part so if we're looking back here
supposedly
let's see urinary
started started started I'm gonna
maximize this a bit
I'm gonna.net run it
to see it how it works
okay yeah of course this died
I'm gonna comment this thing again
seems to be working building unit
I'm gonna clear the screen just so
I'm not seeing it
okay here it is
uh I wasn't inspired enough to create it
so it's an info message like logging
information uh it's in server logging
Interceptor I'm starting to receive a
call of type unary in method greeters
hey hello so I'm intercepting or only
that specific type of um
type of calls and it's up to me what I
do with them so either I'm extracting
claims you can use that you can extract
claims you can extract security related
things where you can log or whatever the
business case you have you can intercept
each one
so
um moving forward
if you talk about security since I just
mentioned that
you can basically use everything that
you use
in a web API and now you have two
options you can put it at the channel
level so for each grpc thingy that
travels through the TCP Channel or at
the connection level so TCP connection
whatever you would use there you're able
to to
extract information and to be able to
see if the call is loud or not
so uh Azure ad client certificate jvd
token I should remove from there or auth
WS Federation and so on
so there are different topics to talk
about security and I'm not going to dig
into it right now but I have a few more
things that I want to show you since
dotnet6 grpc should do some awesome
things in.net and one of them is called
grpc transcoding uh some people say hey
I won't use grpc to my Downstream apis
I'm gonna keep using HTTP calls because
my apis are also I I also need them to
be exposed like to the outside world in
the browser
and I cannot use the RPC for that
without using a grpc web or some other
tools so guess what there is this thingy
called grpc transcoding that allows you
to do exactly that so allows you to do I
have a server that's called transcoding
kbi that listens
uh to a specific port
and I'm going to show you this
sorry sorry
uh basically right now it's it's a hack
but until they release a.net7 I hope
this will be fixed you need to copy from
GitHub some folder structure
uh called Google API with these two
protophiles
and this basically will allow you
to you also need to import them in your
protophile and this will allow you to do
this
to say hey I need to have an option
to expose this as an endpoint in the
browser as in process but to also be in
the browser so in our case they want to
expose a get request under this path the
parameters will be bind bound from the
path
and we'll be able to do this
so https localhost the port that is
running V1 greater and name and we're
gonna get back hello
the parameter that we're sending so if
I'm extending NDC
I'm going to get back hello NDC and this
is very cool because basically what I
have is the grpc servers here it is
complete implementation I have the
option of hey
this is your PC up to my Downstream but
I also need to expose this in the in the
browser
um it's still new fairly new and not
stable enough but it also works with
post requests and it also allows you to
issue requests for example from from the
browser
so I'm sending a name in so in Postman
in beta version you're able to send
messages with grpc and if we invoke this
we're going to get back messages from
Postman
so I think this is very cool because you
couldn't do this before and now you
basically have two rabbits one stone and
you'll be able to to touch them both
so grpc transcoding is one of the things
that is very cool
another thing is Transit fold handling
so if you ever use poly
now you'll be able to use this also
out of the box without using some extra
packages so
here here here
you'll be able to configure either of
your try policy or hedging policy for
each request because this will be passed
through the channel so specific to the
grpc piece so basically you can say hey
what are the max attempts to retry the
initial back off with the time span
maximum back off back of multiplier and
which are the retrievable statuses that
you want to do so basically you won't
sometimes you don't need to retry every
time just when something happens and the
status code that is their triggers uh
the hedging policy again you can specify
hedging delay maximum of temps and which
are the known fatal status codes that
you want to to use again so you can
specify the method config give it a name
that is comfortable for you and then
just pass it for uh pass it to that that
client
okay I'm not gonna demo this but another
thing that I'm gonna demo is
client side load balancing what if you
could do client-side load balancing
without using some additional tools and
now you'll be able to do this what you
have to do is to allow this to have and
to be either a static resolver Factory
or you know the DNS
and you can add the resolver factory so
basically what we're going to do is hey
I need to
uh I know the addresses that I will have
a server running the this port in this
port so every time you want to create
and issue a grpc request you'll be
either be served by one of them or the
other one based on on the the policy
that I'm specifying okay so um I'm gonna
see uh specify hey uh for this address
give it a name localhost I have this
options for the channel the credentials
and I have the service config where I'm
specifying I want it to be round robin
so take one and the next one and so on
and for example if you want to say uh is
the pick first also
or you can also Implement your own so
what I'm gonna do is
okay so we're issuing requests I'm going
to have the server running it's still
running
and I'm going to have the second server
on Port
2002 so two instances of the server
and now I will have another console app
that is
that will be running
an issue requests and we're gonna see
hey uh we got hello back with NDC value
from localhost 5000 and now if I do the
same request
same request let's add
hmm just a sec this is running
I'm running what I need to run
no no no no this should work
what happened
okay
demo Gods today anyways uh I'm gonna try
one more time
extras grpc
clear screen
balance DNS build server console say
hello
transcoding transcoding transcoding
no not this I'm gonna close it
live demos right so
this runs
okay I'm gonna give up I don't know what
happened
yeah but basically client-side load
balancing not in my case apparently but
it should serve you like the first one
and the second one uh before
okay
um
let's see what else do we have
cleanser load balancing so DNS resolver
static resolver Peak first or round
robin policy and if you want you can
Implement your own like take the first
one and after next five requests or the
second server and so on sky is the
limiting here
so
um
I'm still wondering why that demo
doesn't work so what are the benefits of
using grpc first of all I think it's
visible and important enough to look at
the performance versus size so the same
request the same response size for the
HTTP API versus a grpc gives you a
payload that is 80 small smaller in the
payload response just because it's
different serialization uh we'll allow
you polyglot environments which is
important to have a system that is
pretty much serving everything
[Music]
from the language that it's suitable
enough low Network usage point to point
because that's what you expect 0.8 point
B make data traveling over so HTTP
multiple calls over TCP connection is
very important
it's contract based
HTTP 2 supports different streaming
types and it can be configured to run
with HTTP 3. I don't know about you guys
and girls but I'm personally just
getting my head around the HTTP 2 and
now they're talking about HTTP 3s it's
hard to to keep up sometimes uh and
those downsides uh it still has the
temporal coupling so the temporal
coupling will be a thing that will allow
you to stay here not to lose every uh
anything by using a service buses going
messaging and so on and grpc is not the
technology for that
um it's not humor readable it wasn't
humor readable until Postman created the
better version of it and IT addresses
grpc you'll need better testing and
you'll need to focus on cicd in a way
that will prevent you from uh losing
access to the Proto files so if you're
traveling a file over the network you're
gonna make sure that you test that
thoroughly it does only post requests
which means there's no caching for you
yay right no I think there will work on
on solving this also you have the single
point of Truth the protofile so normal
chord references and so on and it's not
supported in Azure it is supported in
Asia after two years they brought
support in Asia
so
when and why grpc so when you have
Downstream apis in your system that you
want so also want to expose to the
outside world it has four ways it's
performant and so on and
um you know distributed systems are all
about trade-offs so we need to pick the
right technology for the specific job
that we have and we should know the
tools so as next steps because um my
time is up is to look up this grpc web
HTTP 3 and stuff like that
and you'll have the resources in here so
it's a demo and so on also uh thanks for
listening uh and don't forget about the
the scoring the cards no Reds uh only
greens uh on your way out so thank you
for listening me
[Applause]